get the view from labor now shall we
we're joined by the shadow culture
secretary Lucy Powell good to have you
on the program Lucy Powell um if I may I
just want to get your reaction first to
the anti-social Behavior Crackdown that
we've seen in the papers today I mean
look parties do this thing from time to
time don't they say they're going to be
tough on crying they're going to crack
down on anti-social Behavior what's your
take on this government policy
well look we've heard it all before from
this government and I think we have to
judge them by their record and Community
sentencing over the last 13 years is
downed not just by a third but by
two-thirds over the last 13 years and
we've heard announcement after
announcement I remember Boris Johnson
saying something very similar to this
about 18 months ago Theresa May before
him saying something very similar they
scrapped the asbo regime that the last
Labor government brought in and under
their watch anti-social Behavior has got
worse sentencing has fallen immeasurably
and we're seeing crimes going unsolved
so yes we hear these sort of reboots and
another reboot and another announcement
to get the the Sunday media retention
but but I think it amounts to nothing
and I think people will judge this
government on their record
in some ways the biggest newsline I
thought that came out of the interview
with him on the antisocial Behavior was
the fact that the government is going to
ban nitrous oxide so laughing gas under
the 1971 misuse of drugs acts now that
does go against the advisory council's
recommendations what's Labor's position
should laughing gasp be banned
I think we we want to see it see it
banned as well because I think it does
cause a huge amount of littering of
disruption uh and of anti-social
Behavior challenges as well I did I did
see that report myself and understand
there are balancing of of use here but
you know we do need to tackle at source
these kind of crimes and this can be
hell sometimes they're not crimes but
these kind of behaviors that are blights
on on our communities and it's it's
something when I go door knocking in my
constituency in Manchester Central and I
go out and meeting residents anti-social
behavior is probably the number one
issue that they that they raise with me
and they feel that they don't have the
police on the beat that they can turn to
and that's why Labor's committed to an
extra 13 000 neighborhood police
officers because we've seen those
numbers dramatically fall over recent
years and they don't feel that they've
got the powers and the safer in the
agency to get these issues tackled in
their in their local community so we
need enforcement we need sentencing we
need people to have the powers that's
local authorities as well as police to
tackle some of these issues and we need
to deal with uh some of these challenges
at source as well so that we can prevent
people from undertaking these kind of
activities whether that's fly tipping
whether that is drug taking drug dealing
whether that's noise pollution and all
of these issues that are real Bliss on
communities we need a comprehensive plan
to do that and and labor has got that
comprehensive plan and you heard from
cased armor last week's laying out his
big vision for tackling crime and
anti-social behavior in this country and
that's why I think it's no coincidence
that the government has suddenly
alighted upon this issue today
and now I want to talk to you with your
Shadow culture secretary hassle because
you're launching an independent review
panel into the BBC one of the things
that you wanted to look into is ensuring
the BBC is independent of government do
you think the BBC is independent of
government right now
well I think there are some perception
uh challenges at least in that regard
and the reason that I've launched this
independent review panel today was some
very preeminent uh people from the
industry working with uh me who are
going to make recommendations and and
advise labor on the future uh direction
is because the BBC does face the number
of headwinds but we're we're sure that
as the labor party that we support a
universally funded Public Service uh
publicly funded broadcaster in this
country we think that's absolutely
critical but there are a number of
headwinds that it faces it's got a
charter renewal coming up there are
constant questions around its future
funding this government have basically
put the BBC uh under threat in terms of
its its future funding its independence
and impartiality is constantly being
questioned and at the center of of
culture wars and course in the in the
streaming age the platform age the
social media age that we are now living
in there are big challenges for the BBC
and that's why I want this panel at this
stage to really do some deep policy work
for labor on these issues so that we can
secure the future of the BBC not just to
survive but to thrive into the Next
Generation
I'm still a little bit unclear on what
the answer to the initial question was
about the independence of the BBC could
you say that there's a perception issue
you said that the independence is being
questioned
do you think it's independent of
government you've called for the
chairman Richard to resign
well I think that there are have been
serious issues uh lately obviously there
are a number of issues around the
appointment process of the of the chair
which is now under investigation because
I asked for that investigation because
quite clearly the relationship between
the chair that was appointed and the
then prime minister was was one a lot
closer and involved a lot of financial
issues that we weren't aware of at the
time the appointment of other members of
of the board of the BBC but also this
keeping I think what we've seen from
this government in particular is is
keeping the BBC at heal by constantly
threatening uh its future so this time
last year the then culture secretary
Nadine Doris said that the license fee
settlement would be the last license fee
as we know it and that there's some in
the future there would be some other way
of funding the BBC yet they've said
nothing about that they were supposed to
bring in a Media bill to secure your
prominence of the BBC they've not done
that there are constant threats that
hanging over the BBC and the charter
renewal coming up in the next few years
is another one which I think is a way in
which that this government is trying to
keep uh its foot on the throat of the
BBC there's a lot of scrutiny with the
BBC and it's impartiality and
Independence what's your view on the
trend of other channels employing
serving MPS as presenters obviously we
have someone like David Lammy on LBC Lee
Anderson the conservative Deputy
chairman earning a hundred thousand
pounds presenting on GB news
well I think it's it's very concerning I
think what is happening on uh some uh
other uh channels in terms of that
overall balance of of opinion and this
issue has been raised with the chief
executive of ofcom both by select
committee members of the of the select
committee recently and also uh it's it's
something that I've been raising uh in
private as well and ofcom should be
looking at these issues because they're
the licensing Authority they're the
regulatory Authority and I think it's
really important that in this era of
decent misinformation we need to know
that we can trust our news channels and
our news sources and it's something that
we are very proud of in this country
because we do have a a strong regulatory
regime and news channels and
broadcasters are bound by those
licensing conditions which mean that
they do have to provide balance and some
impartial quality and and I'm not sure
that that constantly ramming the
airwaves of of any one of those channels
full of sitting conservative MPS is
necessarily the right way of dealing
with that
just one quick question to finish we're
talking a bit on the program today by
MPS outside earnings and undercover
staying from the anti-brexit group led
by donkeys caught some MPS including
Matt Hancock and quasi quite saying
offering to work for 10 000 pounds a day
within the rules is there a problem with
the rules
there is a problem with the rules and I
think no one can watch that video and
see these reports without feeling uh
sickened quite honestly at them parading
themselves around trying to to get extra
paid political consultancy because
that's what that is and that's why we've
been calling for an end to Second jobs
for for MPS and end to these paid
political consultancy roles being an MP
is is absolutely a full-time job it's
not just a full-time job it's a whole
lifetime commitment and our constituents
need us to be fully focused on that not
working out whether we've got other
interests and whether we are pursuing
other commercial ends in doing our job
so I was pretty appalled and sickened by
those uh by those Revelations and that's
why we'll be redoubling our efforts to
try and get second jobs banned for for
MPS okay thank you very much indeed Lucy
pal there talking to us this morning
from Manchester